hi it's michelle from lab muffin beauty
science chemistry phd skin care nerd and
not a sponge yes you heard that right we
are not sponges
and your skin is not a sponge the myth
that 60
of what you apply on your skin will be
absorbed into your bloodstream is one of
my pet peeves
it's so inaccurate but people who are
saying this seem so confident and it's
such a specific number that you kind of
want to believe them
it's used by a lot of clean beauty
brands to freak people out about their
skincare products
so today i'm going to be breaking down
how human skin works and why this is a
myth
first off yeah skin is not a sponge you
don't get massively heavier after you
take a bath
you don't absorb your clothes you still
have makeup to remove at the end of the
day
you can't just slap food you don't like
on your skin to get around eating it you
can't just sit on big tablets to avoid
swallowing them you can't just stick
your hand in vaccine goop to get around
needles
none of us got massively drunk off hand
sanitizer okay maybe you did i don't
know you in your life
this is because your skin has evolved to
be a really good
barrier it's one of its main functions
it blocks things in both directions it
blocks substances that you put on your
skin from getting deeper into your body
and it stops important substances from
leaking out from your body into the
environment
if we absorbed or lost things that
easily we would have died a really long
time ago
like a lot of people do mud runs if
these people were absorbing 60
of what got on their skin then mudphones
would have stopped a long time ago
after 90 of people who did them got
horrific diarrhoea for the next six
months
so by default the amount of stuff that
gets absorbed when you put it on your
skin is going to be closer to zero
percent than
a hundred percent but what about
medicated creams and patches
if skin's such a good barrier why do
these work
yeah science woman how do you explain
that one well the fact that only a tiny
proportion of all the medications in the
world are actually delivered through
skin in creams and patches
if it was easy to deliver medications
transdermally that means through skin
then we'd have a lot more drugs that did
this because
there are lots of advantages to
transdermal medications
one of the biggest headaches in
designing medications is something
called
first pass metabolism this is when your
digestive system gets rid of drugs that
you take
early like in a tablet or a syrup before
they can get to your blood
to get around first pass metabolism a
lot of the time you have to give people
a lot more of that medication so that
after your digestive system does its
stuff
then there's still enough to get into
the bloodstream to have any sort of
effect
you can also just avoid the digestive
system entirely with things like iv
drips and injections and suppositories
what's a suppository
it's when you you know
what what in the or transdermal delivery
through skin in patches and creams
patches are also good because they can
release drugs consistently over a longer
period of time
and there are a lot less hassle for
people than giant tablets or injections
so we would have a lot more transdermal
medications if we could
but we don't because we can't getting
stuff to go through this really
effective barrier that's evolved over
millions of years
is a massive pain in the what what in
the book there are lots of formulating
tricks that are used to get things to
get through the skin and into the blood
so with nicotine patches for example
they mix it with penetration enhancers
that get the nicotine to get through
skin more easily the patch itself stops
water from evaporating that keeps the
skin moist which makes it more permeable
the sticker also stops things from
rubbing off and even with all this extra
help
with current transdermal drugs there's
still about 10 to 95 percent of the drug
left on the skin
unabsorbed at the end so why do some
things absorb through the skin into the
bloodstream
well it mostly depends on what the
substance is which is why that blanket
60
number looks so dodgy to people who
study pharmacology
firstly there's the size of the molecule
the smaller it is
the more easily it squeezes between all
the stuff that your skin is made of
sort of like how you try to streamline
yourself when you get through a crowd
your skin is also made up of watery and
oily parts
things that dissolve in water tend not
to dissolve in oil
and so a substance has to be the right
balance of water and oil soluble
to get into the skin and then also leave
the skin and get into the blood
so as you expect the drugs that are in
transdermal medications tend to tick off
all these boxes
and things that aren't don't and it's
the same for other things that touch
your skin
your skin also doesn't have the same
permeability all over
and so the amount that gets absorbed
also depends on what part you're talking
about
this table over here shows how well
three different substances absorb
in different parts of your body if you
look across the table
then you can see there's a massive
variation in how well different
substances absorb
if you look down the table you can see
the massive range depending on what part
you're putting on some parts of your
body are better at absorbing things so
your armpits your ear canal your jaw
your scrotum other parts of the body
like the foot
your palms your forearms are less
permeable
one thing to note about this table is
this is percutaneous absorption so that
just means absorbing through the skin
not necessarily getting to your blood
there is a lot of stuff between the
surface of your skin
and your blood you can see this on my
handy model the surface of your skin is
up here you apply the stuff here and
then it has to diffuse through all these
layers before it hits the blood
so only a fraction of the stuff you put
on the surface of the skin will actually
make it down to the blood
and that fraction depends on a lot of
things like the blood flow in that area
how thick these layers are you might
also remember the fda studies that got
reported as
sunscreen soak all the way into your
bloodstream the abstract of the first
study had a bunch of percentages and
some people thought that those
percentages were the amounts absorbed
they weren't they were actually the
coefficients of variation which is
a measure of how repeatable the
measurements were but you can actually
roughly calculate
what percentage does get absorbed into
the blood from the data in the paper a
redditor did these calculations
and it turns out that for avobenzone
0.011
gets absorbed into the blood plasma then
doesn't that mean skincare doesn't work
science woman
skincare doesn't have to get that deep
and not at that higher concentration
most skincare ingredients actually work
in the epidermis which is in these top
few layers so when you put the skincare
on your skin
it doesn't have to absorb all the way
into the bloodstream a lot of skincare
ingredients actually work really
effectively in the stratum corneum which
is this very top layer
if you want something to get into your
blood and work somewhere else then it
has to get through all of these layers
and then once it hits the blood it gets
diluted because we have about five
liters of blood
that's about 13 of these i mentioned
this before but there are formulating
tricks that can get things to get into
the skin they're used in transdermal
patches and creams
they're also used in some skin care
products i mentioned covering stuff up
with a patch
that stops the ingredients from getting
rubbed away plus it also keeps moisture
in and moisture helps disturb the skin a
bit
and help things absorb better there's
also penetration enhancers which are
ingredients that help skin absorb things
better
some of these work by making the stratum
corneum which is
this outer part of the skin more liquidy
and the stratum konim is one of the
strongest barrier parts of the skin
and so that can make a big difference
some of them disrupt the proteins and
the oils some of them hydrate the skin
sort of like what a patch does
there are lots of these in skincare this
includes alcohols glycols
some essential oils urea fatty acids
and even just water you can also use
special delivery systems like liposomes
in the products
there are also lots of tools that can
help with penetration like ultrasound
electroporation
iontophoresis heating and microneedles
some of these disturb the barrier and
some of these push the ingredients into
your skin
in other ways but in standard beauty
products
a lot of these aren't designed to
maximize absorption a lot of products
are meant to stay on top of your skin
so sunscreens for example if you absorb
them then they're not going to be very
useful because they'll be below the bits
that you want to protect
so maybe with a few freak things applied
to specific areas of your skin
in specific ways can absorb at 60
into your bloodstream but for the vast
vast majority of things that you put on
your skin
60 is a massive overestimate i hope you
like this video if you have other myths
you want me to debunk leave them in the
comments
hopefully we'll see this myth around
less but i'm not that optimistic to be
honest
it's one of those myths that never seems
to die but hopefully this video is
useful
maybe you can use it in your internet
arguments you can just copy paste it
into the comments instead of wasting
hours of your life
if you like this video give it a thumbs
up you can also subscribe for more
videos like this
you can follow me on instagram and check
out my blog if you like beauty science
and i'll see you next time to hopefully
not talk about sponges